maybe maybe maybe the next Futterman and
all those are going to be fantastic and
and I think Tom's just a great actor so
that might be at home wonderful opera I
I like seeing cat play mentor anybody
you know what I mean he's been through
so much and I think he's a good man so
anytime he can take anyone under his
wing that'd be great I hope Marvel pulls
that off hey youtubers it's Charlie we
just found out a whole bunch about
carnage in the spider-man universe and
there's going to be another Avenger in
the next spider-man movie I of course
have some theories about that so I'll
explain what's going on bunch of
spider-man stuff happening there's a new
brand of the giveaway - for those action
figures all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video the biggest stuff is the
carnage is supposed to be the villain of
the venom movie which isn't a huge
surprise I'll talk about that in a
second but there's a confirmed Avenger
that is going to take the team-up slot
in spider-man homecoming to fit Iron Man
currently has in this movie so that's
like the other really big thing and they
did make it sound like it was going to
be an earth-based Avenger I have some
theories about who that's going to be
they said a list so I'll talk about that
after carnage because the second
spider-man film isn't going to drop till
after the fourth Avengers film so you're
going to get all of the Thanos Infinity
Gauntlet saga then you'll get your
spider-man Avengers team-up I want the
power I deserve is a felony being
organism it must be bought into Ichigo
you hear the carnage is in the
spider-man movie and then you think wait
a minute that means that he's
technically part of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and then you just think about
that Kevin Feige reaction video where he
just like oh Jesus so we have to deal
with carnage now he's like that drunk
uncle that you're not really sure if you
want him to come to Christmas dinner
because you're doing something really
special and you think that he might mess
it up so I think that carnage is a great
character he's perfect for the venom
movie but I don't think that they're
ever going to have to really deal with
them in a big way in any of the Marvel
movies whatever you think the level of
connection is between Marvel and the
Sony spider-verse because the other big
piece of news is that they're developing
spin-off movies for the other sinister
six characters so very clearly
it sounds like Sony is trying to turn
the sinister six into their suicide
kuan eventually so if they have enough
early success they could actually do a
sinister six movie without spider-man
and they would just go after carnage or
somebody that's even worse so I feel
like that would probably the preferable
scenario because if you're going to have
all this Avengers spider-man stuff
happening that it's going to get way
confusing if you see him jumping back
and forth between movies that don't
reference each other in one of the big
problems that Marvel had with the
spider-man character before this big
Renaissance is that he was completely
over saturated so spider-man is always
going to be one of the world's most
popular comic book characters but you
put them in too many movies in too short
a time span and eventually people just
get fatigued so if the venom movie is
going to be venom versus carnage then
obviously there's not going to be too
much spider-man in it and I think people
be happy with that you have to deal with
the origin of the symbiote so that you
can explain where venom came from then
you can explain where carnage came from
because the carnage symbiote is just
offspring of the Venom symbiote is like
a living organism so it can give birth
you don't really learn about where they
come from to the guardians of the galaxy
comic recently just because spider-man
picked it up during Secret Wars and even
though the venom movie is supposed to be
coming out at the end of next year I
don't think that they're going to deal
with Secret Wars symbiote origin I think
they'll just deal with the symbiote when
they get to the venom movie they'll be
like a pre credit sequence there'll be a
flash forward to something that happens
down the road for our version of
spider-man where he gets the symbiote
then loses it it finds venom then you
can go from there you're probably
familiar with the carnage origin story
you probably at least heard about the
maximum carnage series that was
basically spider-man and venom teaming
up to take down carnage they could
always do a version of maximum carnage
I've already done a couple of carnage
videos so I'll link those at the end of
this but the really cool thing is we got
to cast him down
who plays carnage in the Marvel Universe
my number one pick somebody asked me
this on Twitter I forget who you were
but I instantly thought of Dan Stevens
because of his work on Legion if you're
looking for a really good actor who's
really hot right now who just popping up
in all the biggest movies Dan Stevens is
the person you want to get he did an
amazing job with the Legion character
who's a
complete psychopath now Cletus Kasady is
way worse than that but I think that
even though this venom movie is supposed
to be rated R they will pull it a little
back from comic book carnage because he
was really over the top you look at some
of those 90's comics and you're like wow
I can't believe I read that when I was a
little kid and I was actually where I
found the carnage character imagine
you're a little kid you haven't read
spider-man for a little while and you
walk by this and you're like oh my god I
have to read this it looks like his suit
is made of complete blood what is going
on here and I think what they would like
to see is that venom becomes the lead of
their spider verse so they don't have to
worry too much about sticking Tom
Holland in their movies moving on to
Avengers spider-man team-up
so obviously spider-man is going to be
in The Avengers movies but because the
sharing arrangement with Sony is that
they get to pick another a lyst Avenger
to put in the next spider-man solo movie
I'm not talking about Black Widow I'm
talking about Hulk I'm talking about
Captain America maybe even Captain
Marvel now it's not dropping until after
the fourth Avengers film so it could be
any of the new characters that they
introduced but it has to be one of the
big a-list characters they're already
working on that sequel so they probably
already know who the next Avengers going
to be but I think they're just waiting
to see which actors want to continue to
make Marvel films because Chris Evans is
done with his contract after the fourth
Avengers film so after that's done he
could totally walk away and never play
the Captain America character again but
that's why I think that he's actually
the top candidate to appear in that next
spider-man film so I think what they'll
probably do is the Iron Man model where
you get your trilogy like Iron Man got a
trilogy then he just started popping up
in other people's films all films are
Iron Man films now so I think that they
really like the way that works the
chemistry that he has with the other
characters so one of the coolest parts
of civil war was spider-man in Captain
America together on screen so his friend
from Brooklyn will probably pop up in
that next film you got hard kid where
you from
Queen Brooklyn but a lot of that just
depends on Marvel's ability to woo Chris
Evans back like hey why don't you sign a
contract to just appear in these other
films you don't have to carry the entire
film it's still going to be a spider-man
movie but you show up for a little while
help him out give him some guidance and
then you go off on your way so anything
could change it could always be Doctor
Strange a spider-man Doctor Strange
team-up would be badass it would be
super weird but badass I would say
ant-man but he's kind of b-list in
Captain Marvel is going to have her solo
movie after that fourth Avengers film so
I think they're going to be too busy
trying to set her up in her other film
for her to be that main Avenger so
you're really talking about Captain
America or the Hulk and remember that
Bruce banners picture is hanging up in
Peter Parker's high school so he admires
all these people and I think that Thor
is mostly earmarked for more cosmic
weird things so if he shows up in anyone
else's films I think it'll be the
guardians of the galaxy films but let me
know in the comments which avenger do
you want to team up with spider-man in
the next spider-man film I feel like any
of them would be awesome the embargo for
spider-man reviews is up July 29th so
that's when my non-spoilery Home Coming
review will post but what's going to
happen next is they released a whole
bunch of information about arrow season
6 so I'll talk about the villain I'll
talk about the storylines Deathstroke
all the people that may have died at the
end of last season but congratulations
to the latest giveaway winner Aaron
Laughlin please private message me so I
can get your contact details while you
wait for everything click here for brand
new Game of Thrones and you can click
here for that Kevin Feige funny video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome see you guys tonight